The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our unit today
concerns something
called the dot product.
Now it's very easy
to just mechanically
give a definition
of the dot product,
but in keeping with the
spirit both of our game
and of our correlation
between the real
and the abstract world, let's
keep in mind that when it came
time to define vector
addition, we chose,
as our definition, a
concept already used
in the physical world-- namely,
that of a resultant vector.
And now what we
would like to do is
to introduce a further structure
in our game of vectors.
And by the way, keep
in mind that I do not
need any more physical
interpretations
to add more
complexities to my game,
but that perhaps
if we do this, it
makes the subject
more meaningful,
both to the applied person
and to the theoretical person.
The idea that I wanted to
keep in mind for motivating
today's lesson was the old
high school idea of work
equals force times distance in
the elementary physics course.
Well rather than talk on like
this, let's just take a look
and see what's going on.
Let's say the lecture is
called "The Dot Product,"
and our physical
motivation is the recipe
from elementary physics, work
equals force times distance.
Now this is a deceptive
little formula.
First of all, what
it really meant was,
when we learned this
recipe, was that the force
was taking place in
the same direction
as the object was moving.
Now what happened next was
the following situation.
We have an object, say,
being moved by a force.
The object is being moved
along a tabletop, say.
The force is represented
now by a vector, an arrow.
And we're assuming
enough friction
here so that the block
moves along the table
and doesn't rise.
And the question is, how much
work is done on the object
as the object moves, say,
from this point to this point?
Now without worrying
about what motivates
this thing physically,
the important thing was,
is that people observe
that physically,
the only thing that
went into the work
was the component of the
force in the direction
of the displacement.
In other words,
this was the force
that one found had to be
multiplied by the displacement.
In other words, to find
the work being done,
one took not the magnitude of
F, but rather the component of F
in the direction of s.
And in this diagram,
that's just what?
It's the magnitude of
F times cosine theta.
And that quantity, which was
called the effective force,
was then multiplied
by the displacement.
And to write that in
more suggestive form,
notice that the work
was not the magnitude
of the force times the
magnitude of the displacement.
That was only true
in the special case
where the force and
the displacement
were in the same direction.
But that rather
the work is what?
It's the magnitude of the
force times the magnitude
of the displacement
times the cosine
of the angle between the
force and the displacement.
And notice by the way,
the very special cases,
that if F and s happen
to be parallel and have
the same sense, then the
angle between F and s is 0.
The cosine of 0 is 1, in which
case that you have the work
is the magnitude of the
force times the displacement.
The other extreme
case magnitude-wise
is if s and F happen to be
perpendicular, in which case
the angle, of course,
is 90 degrees.
The cosine of a
90-degree angle is 0.
In which case, what?
If the force was at right
angles to the displacement,
the work was 0.
At any rate then,
whether we understand
this physical motivation
or not is irrelevant.
The important point
is, if we want
to keep this structure or
this particular motivation
in a structural form, we now
generalize this as follows.
We simply say, let A and B
be any two vectors, arrows.
And we will define A dot B to
be the magnitude of A times
the magnitude of B times the
cosine of the angle between A
and B. And I write this this
way to indicate an ordering.
In other words, don't think
of A and B as being A and B.
Think of A as denoting
the first and B
as denoting the second vector.
And what we're saying
is the first dotted
with the second is the
magnitude of the first,
times the magnitude
of the second,
times the cosine of the angle
as you rotate the first vector
into the second.
And the beauty of having
a cosine over here
is the fact that what?
If you reverse the angle of
rotation-- in other words,
from B into A-- notice that you
change the sign of the angle,
but the cosine of theta is the
same as cosine minus theta,
so no harm is done
this particular way.
On the other hand, had we been
dealing with sine of the angle,
as we will in our next lecture,
this will make a difference.
But be this as it
may, we define A dot
B to be the magnitude of
A times the magnitude of B
times the cosine of the angle
between A and B. All right?
The two extreme
cases being what?
If A and B are perpendicular,
the dot product is 0.
If A and B are parallel,
the dot product
is equal to the magnitude of the
product of the two magnitudes.
Now the only difficult thing
here, or what we sometimes
call undesirable--
and maybe this
is what separates the new
three-dimensional geometry
from the old
three-dimensional geometry--
is that the cosine of an angle
is particularly difficult
to keep track of, especially
when the lines are
in three-dimensional space.
How do you measure
an angle this way?
You see, in the
plane, it's simple.
You draw the thing to scale.
But in three-space, this
can be rather difficult.
So what we would like
to do is to eliminate
this particular term.
We would like to find an
expression for A dot B
that doesn't involve the cosine
of an angle, at least directly.
And to do this, we simply
draw a little diagram.
And notice that even if A and B
are three-dimensional vectors,
since A and B are lines,
if they are not parallel,
if they emanate
at a common point,
they form a plane of their own.
Let's call that the
plane of the blackboard.
The third side of the
triangle is either
A minus B or B minus
A, depending on where
you put the arrowhead here.
But we've already
discussed that idea.
And the interesting
point here is notice
that A minus B very subtly
includes the angle theta.
In other words, imagine
the magnitudes of A and B
to be fixed.
And now fan out A and B.
As you fan out A and B,
what you're doing is what?
Just changing this angle.
As you change this angle,
notice that A minus B changes.
Namely, as these
fan out, the vector
that joins the two
arrowheads here
becomes a different vector,
both in magnitude and direction.
In other words, whether
it looks it or not,
one of the beauties
of our vector notation
is that the cosine
of the angle theta
is indirectly
included in A minus B.
But now you see, once we
have this triangle here,
notice that the Law
of Cosines tells us
how to relate the third side
of a triangle in terms of two
sides and the included angle.
OK?
And in fact, when we
use the Law of Cosines,
notice that one of the
terms is going to be what?
The product of the
magnitudes of two sides
times the cosine of
the included angle.
And that, roughly speaking, is
just what we mean by A dot B.
So without any
further ado, what we
do now is we just write
the Law of Cosines
down here, which says what?
The magnitude of
A minus B squared
is equal to the magnitude of A
squared plus the magnitude of B
squared minus twice the
magnitude of A times
the magnitude of B times the
cosine of the angle between A
and B. And then,
you see, we simply
recognize that this term
here is, by definition,
A dot B. We can now
take this equation
and solve for A dot
B-- which, by the way,
this is very, very
important to notice.
I should have pointed
this out sooner.
But A dot B is a number.
It's a product of two
magnitudes times the cosine
of an angle, which is a number.
This is a numerical equation.
We can therefore solve for A
dot B. And we wind up with what?
That A dot B is the magnitude
of A minus B squared
minus the magnitude of A
squared minus the magnitude of B
squared, all divided by 2.
And the beauty now is that we
have expressed A dot B solely
in terms of magnitudes.
And notice especially
in Cartesian
coordinates-- and
I'll do that next--
but in terms of
Cartesian coordinates,
notice that magnitudes are
particularly simple to find.
We just subtract
corresponding components
and square, et cetera.
But the important
point is that even
without Cartesian coordinates,
this particular result,
expressed as A dot B in terms
of the magnitudes of A, B, and A
minus B, and is
a result which is
independent of any
coordinate system.
However-- and this is done
very simply in the text,
reinforced in our
exercises-- if you
elect to write A, B and A minus
B in Cartesian coordinates
and use this particularly
straightforward recipe, what
we wind up with is a
rather elegant result--
elegant in terms of
simplicity, at least.
And that is-- remember
in Cartesian coordinates,
we would write A as a_1*i
plus a_2*j plus a_3*k.
B would be b_1*i plus
b_2*j plus b_3*k.
And then the beauty is what?
That A dot B turns out to be
very simply and conveniently
a_1*b_1 plus a_2*b_2
plus a_3*b_3.
In other words,
that to dot A and B,
if the vectors are
written in Cartesian
coordinates-- and
this is crucial.
If this is not done in
Cartesian coordinates,
you can get into
a heck of a mess.
And I have deliberately made
an exercise on this unit,
get you into that mess, if you
fall into that particular trap.
But if we have
Cartesian coordinates,
it turns out that to dot two
vectors, you simply do what?
Multiply the two i
components together.
Multiply the two j
Multiply the two k
components together, and add.
All right?
By the way, to show
you why this works
from a structural point of
view, without belaboring
this point right now,
notice that if you
were to multiply in the
usual sense of the word
"multiplication," form
the dot product here,
you would expect
to get nine terms.
In other words, each
of the terms in A
multiplies each of
the three terms in B.
So that altogether you
would expect nine terms.
The thing that's
rather interesting
here is that notice that i
dot i, j dot j, and k dot
k all happen to be 1.
Because after all, the
magnitudes of these vectors
are each 1.
The angle between our i
and i is 0, j and j is 0.
The angle between k and k is 0.
So that i dot i, j dot
j, and k dot k are all 1.
Whereas on the other hand, when
you take mixed terms, notice
that because i and j,
i and k, and j and k
are all at right angles,
i dot j, j dot k,
i dot k are all going to be 0.
And that therefore, those
other six terms will drop out.
In other words, structurally
what's happening here
is the fact that the three
vectors that we're using here
all happen to have unit length.
And they happen to be
mutually perpendicular.
If they were not perpendicular,
these mixed terms
would appear in here.
In other words, in
general, when you
dot two vectors in
three-space, depending
on the coordinate
system, you can expect up
to nine terms in your answer.
But the beauty is
that as long as we
have Cartesian
coordinates, there
happens to be a particularly
simple, beautiful recipe
to compute A dot B.
Now keep in mind, the A dot B
that we're talking about here
is the same one that
we defined before.
It's the magnitude of
A times the magnitude
of B times the cosine
of the angle between A
and B. All we're
saying is that if we
use Cartesian coordinates,
we can compute it
almost as fast as we can read.
And let me show you that
in terms of some examples.
My first example
is the following.
Let's imagine that
we have three points
in Cartesian three-space.
A is the point 1
comma 2 comma 3,
B is the point 2
comma 4 comma 1,
and C is the point
3 comma 0 comma 4.
We draw the straight
lines AB and AC,
and we would like to find the
angle BAC-- in other words,
the angle theta.
The first thing that
we do-- and this
is one of the beauties of how
vectors are used in geometry--
is that we vectorize
the lines A and B.
We put arrowheads on them.
That immediately
makes them vectors.
We already know
from last time how
to read the vectors AB and AC.
Namely, AB is the vector i
plus 2j-- see, just subtract
component by component.
2 minus 1 is 1.
4 minus 2 is 2.
1 minus 3 is minus 3, et cetera.
So that the vector AB is the
vector i plus 2j minus 2k.
And the vector AC, working
in a similar way, is 2i
minus 2j plus k.
Now the beauty is that we can
compute these magnitudes very,
very quickly by recipe.
And we've just
learned the recipe
for finding A dot B in a hurry.
I mean, well in
this case, I don't
mean A dot B. I mean the vector
AB dotted with the vector AC.
And going through the
computational details
here, we square the
components of AB,
extract the positive
square root,
and we find very easily that
the magnitude of AB is 3.
And the hardest part of these
problems for me, as a teacher,
is to find ones where I find
the sum of 3 squares coming out
to be a whole number.
So I always use the
vector [1,  2, 2],
because that's a
nice vector that way.
Similarly, the vector AC also
happens to have magnitude 3.
OK?
And to find AB dot
AC, what do we do?
Let's just come back
here and make sure
we know what we're doing now.
We simply dot
component by component.
It's 1 times 2, plus 2 times
minus 2, plus minus 2 times 1.
In other words, AB dot
AC is 2 minus 4 minus 2,
which is minus 4.
Now using our
recipe, we see what?
That cosine theta
is AB dot AC divided
by the product of the
magnitudes of AB and AC,
from which we very
quickly conclude
that the cosine of
theta is minus 4/9.
And if you're still mixed up as
to what that minus sign means,
just by way of a quick review
of the inverse trigonometric
functions, you locate
the point minus 4 comma
9 in the xy-plane,
and your angle theta
is this particular
angle here, which
means that in terms
of principal values,
if you look up the angle in
the tables whose cosine is
4/9, that will give
you this angle here.
Subtract that from 180.
And that's the angle
that you're looking for.
But the beauty is what?
That you can now find an angle
between two lines in space
without having to
geometrically worry about what
the angle looks like.
The algebra in Cartesian
coordinates takes care of this
by itself.
The same thing happens when
you're looking for projections
in three-dimensional space.
Suppose you have a
force and a displacement
in three-dimensional
space, and you
want to project a force
onto a line, a direction.
And our next example shows
how the dot product can
be used to find projections.
Namely here's a vector
A, here's a vector B.
And I would like to project
the vector A onto the vector B.
And I would like to find what
the length of that projection
is.
Well, from elementary
trigonometry,
I know that the length
of this projection
is just the magnitude of A
times the cosine of theta.
And by the way, notice if theta
were greater than 90 degrees,
cosine theta would be negative.
And the minus sign would
not affect the length.
It would simply tell us
that the projection was
in the opposite sense of B.
That's all that would mean.
But here's the
interesting point.
If you look at the magnitude
of A times the cosine of theta,
it almost looks
like a dot product.
After all, theta is the
angle between A and B.
And if the magnitude
of B were in here,
this would just be A dot
B. But the magnitude of B
isn't in here.
Of course if the magnitude
of B happened to be 1,
that would be fine.
But the magnitude
of B might not be 1.
And the most honest
way to make it 1
is to divide B by its magnitude.
And what will that give you?
If you divide any
vector by its magnitude,
that automatically
gives you a unit vector
having the same direction and
sense as the vector that you
started with.
In other words,
let u sub B, which
is B divided by its
magnitude, be the unit vector
in the direction--
and by the way,
here direction includes
sense-- in the direction of B.
And notice that the unit
vector in the direction of B
has the same
direction as B itself.
Therefore, to find the
angle between u sub B
and A is the same as finding
the angle between B and A.
In other words, the
kicker now seems
to be that I take
this length, which
is the magnitude of
A times cosine theta,
and rewrite that as follows.
It's the magnitude of
A-- and now remembering
that u sub B has
unit length, I just
throw that in as a
factor-- and theta,
being the angle between
A and B, is also
the angle between A and u sub
B. But this, by definition, is
A dot u sub B.
You see, in other words, to
find the projection of A onto B,
all you have to do is
dot A with the unit
vector in the direction of
B. In fact, to summarize
that without the u sub B
in there, all I'm saying
is given two vectors A
and B, if you dot A and B
and then divide by the
magnitude of B, that
will be the projection of A
in the direction of B. OK?
The projection of A in the
direction of B. And of course,
if you want it the
other way around,
you have to reverse
the roles of A and B.
The beauty of this unit,
in Cartesian coordinates,
is how easy it is to compute A
dot B in Cartesian coordinates.
Oh, another example that you
might be interested in, that I
think is very
interesting, and that's
the special case
where A and B already
happen to be unit vectors.
If A and B already happen
to be unit vectors,
then if we use our recipe
for the formula for A dot B,
we observe that, in this case,
by definition of unit vectors,
both the magnitudes
of A and B are 1.
And we find that A dot
B is then the cosine
of the angle between
A and B. Which
means that if A and B happen to
be unit vectors, as soon as you
dot them, you have
automatically found
the cosine of the angle
between the two vectors, which
suggests a rather
general type of approach.
Given any two vectors, divide
each by the magnitude, right?
That gives you unit vectors.
Dot them, and that
gives you the cosine
of the angle between them.
You see?
In particular, and here's
an interesting thing.
You know, I don't know
if it's that funny,
it just struck me as funny.
Last night at supper as we
were sitting down to eat,
my four-year-old
looked at me and said,
"Dad, did they
have baked potatoes
when you was a little boy?"
And you get the
feeling sometimes
that people think that
the modern world really
changed the old in certain basic
ways that didn't happen at all.
And one of the
interesting points
is that long before vector
geometry was invented,
people were doing
three-dimensional geometry
using non-vector methods.
And one technique that
happened to be used
were things called
directional cosines.
Namely, suppose you were
given a line in space.
OK?
As a vector, if you wish
to look at it that way--
or if you didn't want to
look at it as a vector,
imagine the line parallel
to the given line
that goes through the origin.
As soon as I know what
that line looks like,
I can compute the angle that it
makes with the positive x-axis.
makes with the positive y-axis.
I can compute the angle that it
makes with the positive z-axis.
And those three angles
uniquely determine the position
of the line in space, the
direction of the line.
OK?
And those were called
the directional angles.
You understand that?
That was the three-dimensional
analog of slope.
In other words, to find
the slope of a line
in three-dimensional space, draw
the line parallel to that line
that goes through the origin,
and measure each of the three
angles that that line makes
with the positive x-, y-,
and z-axes.
And what the beauty was
of the dot product was
it just gave us a simpler
way of doing that.
Namely, if A is any vector,
I divide A by its magnitude.
That gives me the unit
vector in the direction of A.
If I now dot the unit
vector in the direction of A
with i-- and after
all, what is i?
i is the unit vector
in the direction
of the positive x-axis.
Since these are
both unit vectors,
this would be the cosine of
the angle between i and A.
And that's just what?
The cosine of the
angle that A makes
with the positive
x-axis-- traditionally,
that angle was called alpha.
So u_A dot i is
simply cosine alpha.
Correspondingly, u_A
dot j is the cosine
of the angle between A and j.
That's the cosine
of the angle that A
makes with the positive y-axis.
That angle was called beta.
This is cosine beta.
And u sub A dot k is
cosine gamma where
gamma is the angle that A makes
with the positive k direction.
And these, being the
cosines of the angles,
these were called the
directional cosines,
and they yielded
the slope of lines.
But one must not believe
that one needed vectors
before he could do
three-dimensional geometry.
What did happen was that
vector techniques greatly
simplified many of the aspects
of three-dimensional geometry.
Well, let's leave
this part for a moment
and close for today by
coming back to our game idea.
Remember that ultimately, all
we will ever use, once we get
started with our game,
all we will ever use
are the structural properties.
Now I've gone through
these in the notes.
I've gone through
them-- well you
go through them
with me in the text
or with yourselves in the text.
Let me just point out certain
properties of the dot product
that are shared by regular
arithmetic as well.
For example, A dot
B equals B dot A.
The dot product is commutative.
Why is that?
Well think of what A dot B is.
It's the magnitude of A
times the magnitude of B
times the cosine of the
angle between A and B.
But that's the same as what?
The magnitude of B times
the magnitude of A--
after all, numbers, we know are
commutative when you multiply
them-- and the cosine of
the angle between A and B
is the same as the cosine of
the angle between B and A.
So these are equal
numerical quantities.
Again, without going
through the proof here,
it turns out that
if you want to dot
a vector with the sum
of two given vectors,
the distributive property holds.
Namely, A dot B plus C is A
dot B plus A dot C. By the way,
if you did want to prove this,
all you would have to do,
if you couldn't see
it geometrically,
is to argue as follows.
You say, you know?
The easiest way to
add and dot vectors
is in Cartesian coordinates.
So let me prove
that this result is
true in Cartesian coordinates.
Carry out the details, and if it
works in Cartesian coordinates,
since the result doesn't depend
on the coordinate system,
the result must be
true, regardless
of the coordinate system.
But it's a very simple exercise
to actually write A, B, and C
in terms of i, j, k
components, compute
both sides of this
expression, and show
that they're numerically equal.
I say "numerically" because
it's crucial to notice
that both expressions on
either side of the equal sign
are numbers.
B plus C is a vector.
A is a vector.
When you dot two vectors,
you get a number.
Finally, a scalar
multiple of a vector
dotted with another vector has
the property that you can leave
the scalar multiple outside.
In other words, you can
first dot the two vectors
and then multiply by the scalar.
In other words, in
a way, you don't
have to worry about
voice inflection
when you have a scalar multiple.
And we will talk more
about these as we go along.
However, what's very
crucial is to notice
that the dot product does
have some difficulties not
associated with
ordinary multiplication.
So I say, beware.
For example,
somebody might say, I
wonder if the dot
product is associative.
I wonder if A dot
B dotted with C
is the same as A dotted
with B dotted with C.
And this is nonsensical.
I wanted to do this with
great dramatic gesture,
but I probably would have broken
two fingers against the board
here.
Let's just cross this
out, so that you won't
be inclined to remember that.
This not only is
false, it's stupid.
And the reason
that it's stupid is
that it's nonsensical, that
these things don't make sense.
Namely, the dot product
has been defined
to be an operation between two
vectors that yields a number.
Notice that as soon
as you dot A and B,
you no longer have a vector.
You have a number.
And you cannot dot a
number with a vector.
In other words,
neither (A dot B)
dot C nor A dot (B
dot C) is defined.
Because you see, a number is
never dotted with a vector.
All right?
And finally, a closing
note, as we've already seen,
if A is perpendicular
to B, then the cosine
of the angle between
A and B is 0.
And that says that if A
is perpendicular to B,
then A dot B is 0.
In fact, this is one of
the most common usages
on the elementary level,
of the dot product,
is to prove that two
vectors are perpendicular.
But, whereas that's
a nice property,
what causes great hardship here
is to notice the following,
in particular, that
if A dot B is 0,
we cannot conclude that either
A is the zero vector or B is
the zero vector.
For example, i dot j is 0.
But neither i nor j
is the zero vector.
You see, with
ordinary arithmetic,
we had the cancellation
rule, things
that said if the product of
two numbers is 0, at least one
of the factors must be 0.
With the dot product,
this need not be true.
The thing I want you to
get from this lesson more
than anything else, other
than the applications
that you can get from the
book and from the exercises,
is to learn to get a
feeling for the structure.
Don't be upset that certain
vector properties are
different than
arithmetic properties,
and certain ones are the same.
Notice in terms of the
game, we take our rules
as they may apply and
just carry them out
towards inescapable conclusions.
But I think that will become
clearer as you read the text
and do the exercises.
And until next time, when
we'll talk about a new vector
product, let's
just say, so long.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.